a lot of people tend to think the c2 as
the ultimate goal of language learning
but the truth is that speak in a foreign
language at a c2 level and speaking like
a native speaker are two different
things
hi my name is Luca from Lucca and
panakam and today I'm going to show you
the difference between speaking on a c2
level and speaking like a native speaker
have you ever caught yourself using
expressions such as he speaks like a
native speaker he sounds like a native
speaker but the reality is that speaking
and native speakers don't go well
together in one sense native speaker is
about identity is not just about the
knowledge it's not just about the skills
a native speaker is a native speaker and
if you're a foreigner if you're a
non-native speaker well you're not a
native speaker that's an important point
to take because a lot of people strive
for speaking like a native speaker
sounding like a native speaker but the
reality is that this is just a mere
emulation just to give you an example
let's take a Danish professor or a
French professor who has been living in
the US for a long time and speaks
English really well so well in fact that
he gives lectures at university and he
is much appreciated by his students
well that Danish professor speaks
English has acquired native-like skills
so he can speak at a native like level
he can express himself very well but
he's not a native speaker on the other
hand let's take a peasant a person who
is a native speaker still he was born in
the United States but has no formal
education who do you think speaks
English better among the two obviously
the peasant probably speaks English
worse he cannot express himself as
eloquently and as elegantly as the
professor but the reality is that he is
still the a native speaker in this show
so who speaks English better the Danish
professor or the American peasant on the
one hand the Danish professor can
express himself very eloquently can
speak really well can write essays the
peasants though although he cannot do
all these things still has an advantage
and the advantage is that he was born in
the United States so
he has incorporated all the customs ways
of saying ways of being facial features
gestures experiences that the Danish
professor probably didn't have because
he did acquire knowledge he did acquire
the skill of express himself elegantly
and eloquently but he was not born there
he did not have the same experiences so
you can learn to speak almost like a
native but bear in mind that you will
never be a native speaker you can
emulate the status of a native speaker
without being one the people who get
very close to speaking and being a
native speakers are normally the people
who live 30 to 40 years in a country and
they their kids were born in that
country so they've seen the entire thing
maybe from an external perspective they
didn't go to the kindergarten but
they've seen their kids go to
kindergarten and interact with other
kids and interact with other adults and
they've seen adults themselves
interacting with kids going to school
going to high school etc those get close
to speaking and being native speakers
but again that will never be native
speakers because they were not born in
that country
so if there is one thing for which
people can say or can think that you are
a native speaker is accent if you speak
a given language very very well to the
point where people cannot tell that
you're a foreigner well that means that
you have reached a native like
pronounciation and if you want to reach
native like pronunciation in a given
language you have to take into account
other things people normally tend to
think okay well what I have to do is
focus on the text focus on sounds
replicate sounds repeat etc true but I
think that one of the most important
factors that is often neglected is that
you have to take everything into account
the entire communication tool that every
single native speaker has and by
communication tools I mean my hands ko
speed gestures my face how I'm
communicating with my face my eyes my
body everything the whole thing just to
give you a few examples
an Italian might sound like a stereotype
but we actually do that
actually this ate my kid stuff ah this
isn't Rome right what are you doing we
tend to use that especially when we ask
questions with an interrogation mark
mega stuff ah or a Spanish would say but
okay they buy some ads so you see the
entire expression get a buy some nacho
or Sackman
bits to the show a Torah or the French
would go like Bob
suppose if I loosen your mouth the poly
so you got the entire set these are just
a few samples of how different cultures
channel different ways of saying things
and and the acts of does count your
pitch your intonation your articulation
your pronunciation but the truth is your
hands your face your eyes do count and
if you want to speak and sound them pass
off as an even speaker even if you're
not pay attention to these watch movies
pay close attention how people
communicate with each other adult with
adult kid with kids pay attention to
every single detail because they do
count and you can learn these
consciously and unconsciously
[Music]
it should be fairly obvious by now that
speaking like a native or passing off
like a native is not just a matter of
sounds it's a holistic process but there
is one third factor which makes a
difference and it is cultural
understanding how many times have we
found ourselves talking to native
speakers and you've seen two native
speakers talking about stuff that you
had no idea of you know no clue and this
can refer to I don't know people on TV
or like TV series or maybe TV shows or
something to happen historical things
giraffe achill things etc etc this is
part of culture this is the part of
heritage that a given generation of
native speakers has and bear in mind a
given generation of speakers because
language learning its hues its its
cultural references they do change in
space and in time
so if we're speaking for example about
English Brits maybe don't understand
certain cultural references of Americans
for Americans certain things Ritz and
maybe the same Americans of now might
not understand things that were very
common 200 years ago that's reason why
it's so difficult to nail a language
because it changes in time it changes in
space it changes its cultural references
that's why it's so difficult when we
talk about being a native speaker
actually we should talk about being a
native speaker of that place and of that
time and that's that's the cultural
references that you will never be able
to replicate because you were born in
another time or maybe in the same time
but unfortunately in another place I
just wanted to say before we wrap up the
video that this is not supposed to be
discouraging I don't want to just put
you down and say hey you will never be a
native speaker it's just a fact you will
not be a native speaker but you can pass
office one does this happen to me many
times and I can guarantee you that even
if I'm not American I'm not French and I
will never be not German for that matter
or any other nationality I've had an
amazing time every time people thought
that I was one of them
because through sound you can actually
embrace another reality embrace another
culture and and embrace an historical
moment people communities you name it so
it's always worth speak in a foreign
language
it's always worth passing off as a
native if you can if that's your aim
apart from speaking you know at an
excellent level because it opens worlds
it makes your life richer in so many
ways you cannot even start to fathom
[Music]
so the first point to take into account
is that speaking like a native does not
equal being like a native because being
like a native is just a unique
characteristic on native speakers and
that's fine the second point to take
away is that if you want to sound like a
native speaker you should not only speak
like a native speaker that is with good
articulation and pronunciation but also
acts like one with ko gestures reactions
facial features you name it it's just
like a little bit like acting and the
third thing if you want to pass off as a
native speaker is that you should
integrate and being able to understand
the same cultural and historical
references and maybe from TV and TV
series etc then native speakers do in a
given space and in a given time if you
liked the video and you haven't
subscribed yet please subscribe and
click on the link below there's a
wonderful article waiting for you about
this very same topic with more examples
you can also listen to it you name it
there's a lot of stuff there please head
over my blog and my website you will not
regret it
[Music]